are you able to come on this podcast and
say that I don't remember exactly what
you said but it was something like men
are trans right but then I said okay but
I'm saying what men are trash that's
common in society right women are trash
is it men are held accountable all the
time every day
no we're at a low we offer less demand
than ever the average age of first men
men value Purity in youth yeah Purity
youth Beauty women are fatter than ever
before we're older than ever before and
we're less youthful than ever getting
married and we have more bodies than
ever so so we bring less to the table
than ever how many women have a cookbook
of just recipes that they made
themselves how many women have that that
you know
what's her name different Nigella Lawson
okay you're thinking your own recipes
that you've written in there that can't
stand
wait what do you mean yeah that's
exactly how many women have a cookbook
how many women know how to do it how
many women are neat and organized
domestically how many men can build
stuff how many men
um can fix up at home
not all men can say that dude
let's just do it let's just do all right
do any do any of you have a cookbook of
recipes you've written yourself Auntie
any of you I can I can cook a lot of it
yes I do do you have recipes that have
been passed down generation to
generation
name five
um we have a special fried rice that we
cook we have fish stew um African we
have a cookbook we have recipes how many
of you are virgins
[Music]
this is what men care about like the
ideal woman for most men is a virgin 20
22 year old roughly that are most
attracted to 22 year olds right you know
honestly there's some data that says
younger some some says 18 some says even
younger so let's not go let's go with
22. you can actually say something right
just to um
my man when I was growing up I was in a
dance group with this girl
and this girl was the most sexiest hot
girl and he always went on about her and
I went out with I went I met her over
the couple of weekends ago and I said
yeah I saw your girl he goes oh she
looks so hot
you know I mean and I showed him a
picture of her not a video it went awful
he said to me do you know what right
you've upset me all the next day he was
talking about it I couldn't sleep all
the next day she went from like a 68
year old to like a size 20 well
and he couldn't believe that it's the
same person I said I look a lot better
in your eyes now didn't I but I never
had no problem with him looking at other
women
because I know that we're coming into my
way say that was your crush back then
that's why I was happy to show him
that women let themselves go they've
always got so much to talk about the men
but when they get to a certain age they
let themselves go on the splits but to
get the same men yep well it's nine
times out don't keep up they don't keep
up the energy they don't keep it up no
no no fake it women women they default
of that put it this way here when we was
all in school there wasn't
AE 19 20 year old women pulling up in
cars to pick up the yeah
there was a 19 year old men putting on
cars to pick up the hottest year 10 year
11 go that that so it just goes to show
women 100 they Peak earlier and then how
many times have you seen like for the
menu like within your friendship groups
and whatnot there was that girl that for
certain man wasn't attainable in school
yeah she was like I said the AE 19 year
old was picking up all the or the bad
issue in school
but fast forward you meet you buckle
down the line like at 24 25. all of a
sudden she's following you and she's
she's
showing
interested because she's lost the things
men value now because she's probably
older she's probably fatter and she's
probably slept with more dips
yeah and you've caught because you've
gained more value yeah and but that's
we're so brainwashed that we literally
think like women we literally think
we're the prize when we offer less than
ever but what's the whole thing with
Factor like you've said fatter a few
times like
women that's not true then why does
every rich man have a Victoria's Secret
model or someone that looks like one but
they still cheat but they still cheats
guys cheating isn't winning the winning
is the girl that gets the ring and the
girl that gets the deed it's not winning
just because just because you got a dude
to sleep with you guys will sleep with a
hole Yeah that's not a that's not a
prize
about the fact but I just think it's a
lack of discipline that when you see
somebody's overweight you gotta think to
yourself because everybody gets caught
up whenever you say whenever you mention
the word fat and there's somebody fat
around some most of the time they always
get a fence to it but you can only say
like you said if you're fat you're fat
no no no no no let me finish because the
women it always seems to think like oh
yeah
lack of discipline
that's what the men are seeing they're
not saying oh yeah you got a bit of what
they're thinking well I'm gonna she
can't control it because you control
money because you control herself
because she control and that's what
they're thinking about because the
biggest sign I don't care whether people
say oh they eat they're sick they're
this they're they're whatever they
whatever they were ever it's like a
discipline bill got fat
I see Pearl going out there and doing
the gym and they know having a talk
today about more not more protein less
carbs and all that so
as far as I'm concerned she's trying to
do something about it even though she
got cut back on all them cupcakes but
she's she's gonna he's gonna make us
suffer for it
he's gonna make her suffer for it but me
now I got the same clothes
as when my son was young and what I find
to realize now is that I tried on the
dress the other day and it looked like
it was swallowing me I'm a size eight
the dress is a size eight and what I
realized now is that when I'm seeing
these fat people say oh yeah I'm a size
10 I figure you can't be a size 10. you
know what because the people that are
making the clothes are making a size 10
bigger so me now I can go in certain
places and I have to buy a size four or
size six I'm not a size four and a size
six I'm a size eight to ten granted to
say that's what you are now you know
what I mean but if that's the case then
you got the people there that normally
14 and 16 and that's in their size 12.
but that's what men that women always
say oh they're always saying that we're
fat you know what cause a men say as a
lack of discipline the main thing is
like you cannot be cooking good home
cooked food and being that size
with what Auntie saying at all because I
feel like there are men out there that
okay there are men out there that don't
care about the size and narrow men out
there that specifically going for bigger
Gods I remember that they even are
feeders they purposely okay okay
like fat women I get it obviously being
fat is not in society it's not seemed as
being attractive but however I don't
think it's fair to say what what percent
of guys I don't know statistics no I'm
saying like come on let's just be like
let's just be real for a second yeah
let's be real what percent of guys is
that common men to be like this is what
girls always do it's every time we make
a point that's for the men and that
makes sense we have to bring up the
exception if if that was the case then
you would see the men with the most
options the most handsome men and the
most rich men with fat chicks but
they're not but the men no the men that
date fat the men that date fat chicks
it's usually they don't have as many
options and some girls get away with it
a little bit more because they're shaped
better they have a pretty face but by
and large men just don't like fat girls
would you go to the chicken shop and buy
a bone and a bear chicken with no meat
on it
would you go to the chicken shop and ask
for a side rest with no meat they might
like ass and boobs but they don't want a
gun that's the ultimate for like chicken
back yes I do but then you go do you go
to the chicken back to chicken breasts
you go to the chicken shop to buy
chicken with no meat on it no you don't
you want some meat on your chicken okay
that comparison makes no sense
I've heard like like in from what I can
hear and see is like the common problem
today is that
the young women of this generation they
think they know what men want and they
say with such like such convictions
that's conviction but you just need to
listen and ask a bit more because
there's men in the room there's men
within your life like yeah you you can't
truly say you you know what a man wants
because quite clearly in almost every
time you've been wrong so no no we only
based off of what men say because men
are the ones
okay okay
do you would you do you think it's any
validity that these are all random dudes
that I barely know barely that random so
this is at random so if they give you an
answer and it's all the same would you
say that says something about men so I'm
gonna ask them I don't know what they're
gonna say I don't know them I can't
influence them I would say that a lot of
men follow each other's mentality right
so they don't speak that on June I don't
think they speak their real food and I'm
gonna follow up and say as well there's
like men that that deep down they love
big girls but they're embarrassed to
show it because they're mandem their
group don't like big girls so if they
speak up and say well I like it like you
just said you like big girls that's real
because most guys will follow what each
other man says and I feel like maybe
maybe like I feel like early 2000's 100
being thick being even my size like
obviously I'm a bigger girl in there I
don't think I'm fat other people might
think I'm fat but I know I'm I'm a
bigger guy don't worry no no but I'm not
saying it like that I'm just saying I'm
like you said be real so I know what
people would think about me but I know I
think about myself but but now I'm
talking now back in the day yeah you're
right being fat was a No-No but if we're
talking now it's like it's completely
they're making songs about it because
girls wanna girls want to be brain like
this is the thing they brainwash us this
is what they're doing they're making you
think that men like fat chicks I'm
telling you I've talked to hundreds
hundreds of men if they have a choice
between a girl with a big ass big boobs
and small waist or a good a girl with a
gut and both they're
sorry one second Auntie yeah just let me
finish this but what I'm saying is men
that means men are chatting [ __ ] because
online now all you see is I want to go
with a fupa because I want to go with
with I wanna I wanna okay you got like
who has more social media men or women
social media is for women it is for
women they Pander to us together it is
for absolutely four women women make 70
to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions they're trying to sell you
something
that's what they're doing do you know
something right people just need to come
off people just need to come off social
media because
you've got real men here in the flesh
telling you what they like and you're
saying she said yeah but online well
yeah but she's saying but online they
tell me you cannot see guys on like guys
online Gaslight okay okay
do you guys like fat chicks if so how
fat no I don't no no it's not it's not
my preference okay but I've slept with
one experience have an experience but no
okay
would you date a girl bigger than you
I'm bigger than me yeah no because I'm
going down okay okay I was I was a very
small guy just got big but I'm going
back down now okay okay so all right a
girl let's say let's say 200. what 200
200 too fat
I
a girl you a girl you take out in public
sleeping with doesn't count you have to
take her out in public
okay my girlfriend here you can't my
mother would have a problem with that
I'm not gonna lie still okay okay 170.
and what's that installed
um
150.
what's that in Stones man [ __ ] do you
know
sorry you need to turn my thing up big
dog okay but but in general no bigger
than you smaller than you
okay all right then let's do sizing
clothes 14 16 18 20.
oh Mommy why man I could have pressure
okay okay okay so you said no fat girls
you said maybe this is chunky 12 okay
and
no no
no but doesn't add blessing yes or no
blessing
all right we're gonna just one more guy
okay I actually wanted to add more I
wanted to go on go ahead go ahead go
ahead go ahead adding on to what Auntie
said this sorry it's not even just about
like look it's about the health thing
you know especially if you want to be
with long term you've got to think
diabetes you've got to think like the
heart rate you gotta think even just
basic stuff like
her being able to see her toes like well
because if you're a fat you're gonna
have health problems someone's got to
take care well this is what I'm saying
he's being nice it boils down to
Lifestyle don't it like like me I'm an
active guy go to the gym so for me I
need my girl to be going to the gym yes
I said discipline he's being nice yeah
he's as a man yeah
see the health stuff yeah cool that's
yeah you maybe you don't want her to
drop dead but I never I tell you a big
thing what man think about you Diane is
yummy and a woman that's like borderline
you even breeder yet yeah she even
breathing when the baby and hear what
I'm saying the comfortability of of me
can know your woman there's a certain
comfortability where inevitably she's
gonna gain a couple because now that
you're off the market so this is why
women say they don't do nothing
typically when you're off the market
you're getting a couple when
so guys think about that so if you're
already borderline yeah the average with
every kid it's like 30 pounds on average
which is it which it shouldn't be but
that's that's what it is
listen yeah straight wow women with mums
and say yeah we reckon she might always
say that if you want to see what your
future look at the woman's mouth I
thought I was the only man that done
I'm gonna drop some game for you girls
yeah look women control sex men control
marriage in it so at the end of the day
you can sleep with as many guys as you
want but the guys that you want you need
to conform to what they actually want so
you have to listen to what men actually
want you know I mean like
of my girl managed to get me locked down
because I met her she was submissive she
could clean anything I needed she did it
finished cooking he takes the plate away
and that's I I don't have to do anything
I go to I go to a flat I just sit there
and that's I don't have to do anything
she just she just wants to serve me look
after me do everything she goes to the
gym keeps herself looking fit she
listens to me if we go out for dinner or
something and I don't know what she's
wearing she comes out and I give her I
don't say anything if I if I if I'm not
looking at her going I love that she's
like I'm gonna go change
like because she's just she wants my
approval you know I mean so so that is
what men want really because me I don't
need to look elsewhere no more you know
what I mean so that is what men want and
and women are so hard-headed that they
don't want to listen to that because
they want to just believe this
yeah it's not a weakness
you're doing too much no it's a strength
because I know what they're going to say
why can't you quote for yourself why
does a woman have to cook for you why
does it women can't cook but they don't
feed that men could cook for themself
and the woman is choosing to cook for
you
why aren't you telling her she makes all
these choices you're insecure because
from the time a man's telling the woman
that she needs to lose weight or she's
too fat you're insecure once she's doing
is you're saying it's not her being
submissive you're treating her like it's
a choice and she and my girl makes these
choices because she knows it's going to
make me happy and her priority is just
to make me happy because making me happy
he's gonna make her happy because the
happier I am
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis
in this plot platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible